selbst für die video leute ich bin hier
zusammen mit luca und die haben zu
bereit sind titel gelesen ich mache die
besten burger der welt bis nach der
kläger muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen aber
ich habe in den letzten monaten nun
nicht hochgeladen weil ich
perfektioniert habe hatte ich vielleicht
hätte ich meine passion beschrieben wird
auch frauen und das ist aber alles jetzt
hoffentlich vorbei und ich mache wieder
mehr
ich dachte ich schon weil ich mir heute
auch so wird halt wo wir auf einem
gräberfeld burger gemacht und jeder ecke
das ist ja nicht die besten burger
display mit sonderbare angaben gar nicht
genau was ich zeigen
ich nehme ich jetzt was man braucht für
die besten völker der welt mit einem
trip gleich not krankheit ist sitzt wenn
man das frisch folgt aber da habe ich
jetzt nicht hinbekommen zu bringen
eigentlich nicht die besten burger wenn
es nicht gewollt ist
und so bringen damit die sozialen
netzwerke bieten wollten ein bisschen
schade sehr schade
ganz wichtig der billigste entwickelten
schießt schaltet jetzt wunderbar jahres
nach ist laut ihm ist für günstige
vorstellung in zwei kategorien von
baganz geht die gehlberger so das sind
so sachen so 5 k s mcdonalds burger das
genau dafür für die einst die einen
burger und die andere seite mörder ist
hans im glück oder
so zwei sorten und sag's euch die kasten
server die geilsten bürger wo man das
beste gefühl trägt das beste will sind
die gehlberger deshalb machen wir mit
merkel tief ganz wichtig ich war vor
diesem video in vier supermärkten und
das zu besorgen sind privatbürger bahn
ist das sind so spezielle weiche soft in
börger muss man haben und ansonsten
ketchup mayo ich habe auf den
kindergeburtstag für hat mit riesigen
standards mit soße samenkörner braucht
ja gar nicht geld automatisch nach so
schlecht fortan ist uns wichtig wie bei
max dem kanzler auch ohne amt aber in
den bürgertreff eigentlich ein mann mit
das ist eigentlich ziemlich einfach wenn
ihm das hackfleisch und machen ffv
kleine held gemachte salate und du weißt
du gar nicht auf
irgendwie geschmack zwiebeln salat
tomate wofür ganz danach hatte ich auch
er ist kein bürgerlicher das genau ist
und daneben oder edward wird wird man
nicht mit mir das schon vorher stark
wir haben aber müde aber die ist echt
bewährten hause salz pfeffer und jetzt
müssen wir 80 gramm
welche nation wichtig aus dem fleisch
machen denn wir machen das ist ein 400
gramm das heißt wir müssen die in fünf
leichte probleme
das ab 180 gramm
das heißt die 80 plattform wird zum
mädchen nun hat die seite der nächste
880 gramm 82 der wirtschaft sprechen
hören
die bomben mit offenheit übrigens schon
vor dem musste richtig heiß weil ich
kenne dieses konnte welche wegberger
tore was er gemacht hat als er in die
zehn millionen abonnenten
er halte seine hinten el
es war die genau so groß waren
jedoch spricht also durchgeschnitten die
zwiebel nochmal kanalisieren grill drauf
und taxis ja das habe ich auch wegen des
angreifers und ich mir auch sicher dass
natürlich auch für der westbürger welt
natürlich nicht klick welt aber er ist
halt durch ganz lecker eine sekretärin
besser als
der trend ist das ist ja das ist ja auch
max 10 millionen abonnenten zum beispiel
hier gerade tatsächlich gesagt dass das
nicht daran erinnert etwa musste
natürlich auch für einen kanal sagen das
ist ein neues jahr bekommen hat bei der
name of equals schilderte herzlich
willkommen in zweiter und 20 ich glaube
das wird ein super gutes jahr
ich glaube nicht wüsste nicht was
passieren sollte das wird unser letzter
macht ja sind das aber noch nicht in
sicht kam bisher maßlos enttäuscht
bp sollte ganz fern sich die bällchen
sitzen und ihr seht es hier das ist was
wir brauchen
das sind die zutaten die bürger direkt
ist auf 100 und so zeit also scheiß
presse alter das feld etwas zu sagen
habe wird inzwischen euro gewesen
wir brauchen jetzt noch schwierig ist
schon was anderes
ich habe ja schon gesagt wir machen uns
menschen fördern das ist auch die
besonderheit also 80 gramm sind ja wenig
für ein paket das machen wir auf zwei
spiel kauft er klar die sache ist
matchball man tut dieses elche auf dem
grill und smash des runter bis ganz
flach ist und dann halt den besten
burger tests zuletzt in den lichtlosen
wirklich so auch nochmal hätten normale
mal im ketscher meine jetzt nicht
die rassen der komplett aus dungeons
barbecue saucen man kann also vergessen
machen und so aber das ist sekundär bei
der eigens vom ausgang des menschen oder
interpretiert deutlicher kommt es
einfach sehr spärlich oder die kette so
viel weiß nicht mal die hand nehmen so
kraftvoll und wirtschaft stellen was ist
das jetzt brauchen ist fast bei 300 grad
das heißt wir sind ja so langsam in der
dimension wo wir hin wollen und das hier
ist wirklich das ende also mit diesen
dingen hier hält man es drückt man die
bürger platz und dadurch werden die so
die sie werben würde sagen leute die
werden wir so gern ich irgendwas
erhältlich
nun hat kürzlich ein bisschen essen weil
dann sind energie dann eingespielt ich
will sie eigentlich einfach nur zu
zeigen
sie lassen natürlich auch plastik dran
bin ich auch mit 1 34 auf erwähnten das
will ich auch machen und mit
frankfurt ist nur dass auch jeder behält
ich habe diese zeit nicht noch nie
gesehen
du wirst du vielleicht checken fühlen
sagt okay ihr seht schon leute der ist
jetzt schon durch ne damit man das
mitmach starten sache abkratzen und
texte
derzeit erzeugt dabei bürger bisher
wirklich einmal auf den kriegen was
sonst immer nur der pfanne und das halt
so ein akrobatisches und haben durch die
hier zeit also der probleme natürlich
komplett werden schwant auch das bedeute
ich mach schnell ganz kurz zu und jetzt
kommt ohne regen fällt immer auf dem
käse drauf so muss ein bisschen an seite
das ist gut sie hält doch das musste
sein das ist jetzt ein bisschen mein job
ist der wichtigste hier werden sehr sehr
auf die basics unterbrochen bürger wenn
das schmeckt ist so ein bisschen geld
aber das ist eine nummer eins view hat
aber auch alle textilien
das system machen wo natürlich somit
[Musik]
power.de gekommen gibt ihnen hier und du
musst dich somit fast und runter bringt
denn auch ja ich mache die letzten
bürgerhäuser und deren sehr mit dieser
inszenierung dieser ist aber warten drei
deine performance ist schon ähnlich wie
sie einst so genau was zu tun
das förderband vorsatz so dabei geht es
zunächst level damit wirklich nur dann
kommen die banken auch mit klar
sturm ich habe schon mal gesagt
schnellsten videos wir müssen jetzt auch
für dich mach ist dass hier bis er der
beste bürger
ich sag's euch ehrlich das ist kein spaß
vielleicht könnte ich euch vorstellen
aber er war ziemlich komplett kann ich
zeigen mal kurz im querschnitt das zum
bürger das recht der bürger planten
bereits gesagt dass anlagen wissen diese
gurken was das kind vermutlich gerade
ist gut - aber wahrscheinlich schon
längst online
das erlebt ich hätte vorher gedacht wenn
lose drei guthaben hingestellt das ist
so und wie soll der gerne schmecken aber
dadurch dass zu wenige zutaten sind ich
doch nicht nur noch der kammer darüber
wollte der lenker zog in der es kein
salat braucht erst ein richtiges
aufrichtigkeit normal
die krise ist nicht der beste jackson
war ein weißt du deinen hund zur erfüllt
von diesem unser kloster aus dem smash
tätig sein
wenn also den burger vergleich kannst
mich jetzt auch wenn wir denn jetzt so
verweist somit stand zu halten
wieder war es gar kein fan davon kannst
du glück und hamburg geht am piano
irgendwo weil ich gar nicht die sind
normalen bürger so weit ist er ja ganz
schön harte schale hat auch unter last
das geht hier ja da bleiben also die
basics runtergebrochen denn das gar
nicht schmeckt ich bin aber immer tiefer
ins thema geriet finde ich merk
verhalten gute pizza machen könnten
man darf sie auch nicht so elegant ist
man wäre das ist einem jahr wurde
einfach erfüllt ist und mit dem fleisch
und käse nicht der sommer doch gar nicht
so richtig kraft zu retten sind halt
gegeben nur die gene so den krieg die
meisten es ab dass und wie die leute wir
genießen jetzt den bürger zu ende
aber irgendwie mal so ein kleines kopf
video zu machen wie gesagt hoffe dass in
nächster zeit ist oft mehr videos kommt
auch schon das ein oder andere mal von
mir gehört dass drei haben sorgen ich
muss ihn für sich sprechen lassen
deshalb will ich gar nicht noch mehr
macht gutes reden wollte